cérès solutions pour l'emploi à laquelle
on n'avait pas encore pensé heureusement
la compagnie aérienne ryanair a trouvé
la solution
baisser les salaires de ses employés
pour sauver leur emploi entre 20 % pour
les pilotes et 10% pour les personnels
navigants et tout ça pendant cinq ans en
contrepartie une baisse du temps de
travail de 20 % et si les salariés
n'acceptent pas il y aura des
licenciements
un bon petit chantage à l'emploi des
familles pour une entreprise qui a
réalisé quand même un milliard d'euros
de bénéfices sur son dernier exercice
2019-2020 clos fin mars
la mesure a en tout cas fait réagir
jusqu'au gouvernement
muriel pénicaud ministre du travail a
fustigé ryanair dénoue sent donc une
forme de chantage
sauf que si l'entreprise peut mettre en
place ces mesures c'est justement grâce
à muriel pénicaud et au gouvernement
tout juste président emmanuel macron
avait réformé le code du travail à grand
renfort dans dawn ans mettant en place
les accords de performance collective
des accords guirande à peu près tout
négociable pour un patron au sein de son
entreprise
et lorsque ce sont les emplois qui sont
menacés
la situation est forcément intenable
pour les élus qui doivent les valider